let's start by defining a database
contract between our data and our model
a contract is an agreement between our
data model and our views describing how
information is stored it will contain
all the fields that our user interface
will display let's go into Android
studio to begin coding we'll add a new
package to our project named data to
encapsulate the data model next we'll
create a contract class to store our
column information the inner classes
within our contract class will be used
to define tables each table will
implement base columns because the
columns represented by base columns are
useful the ID column in particular must
be a part of our table in order for our
content provider integration to work
later on in this lesson